All right, welcome, everybody.
We continue to try to on The Daily Show, the
podcast, et cetera, bring you sort of the
latest news.
Normally, this is not a program where if we
wait 90 minutes, we might have something different
to report to you.
But because ballots are still being counted
in a number of key states in the presidential
election and there are even things still happening
at the Senate level and House level, we're
trying to figure out how to bring you the
latest information at whatever time we do
it.
And at this point in time, we do have changes
to report to you from where we were yesterday.
No winner has yet been declared in the presidential
election between Donald Trump and Joe Biden.
I'm going to get to the vote counts and to
the scenarios momentarily.
But what you must understand is that all of
our worst worries about how Donald Trump would
react have happened.
We covered some of them yesterday and we will
cover some more of them today.
Donald Trump, of course, declaring victory
late Tuesday, early Wednesday, 2:00 a.m.,
saying we've won yesterday.
Donald Trump and Eric Trump and Rudy Giuliani
and others saying on Twitter, we won Pennsylvania.
Pennsylvania has not yet been called.
And the margin, it continues to shrink away
from Donald Trump's favor and in Joe Biden's
favor, although Trump still leads and I will
show you what those numbers are.
And the latest, which we will also be covering
today extensively, is that the Trump campaign
now claims to be filing multiple lawsuits
in various states.
In some states, we know that they've actually
filed them and others they've said they are
filing them, although we don't actually know.
And we have heard from Joseph R. Biden Jr.
as well.
Joe Biden giving a short but very appropriate
and quite frankly, very presidential speech
in Wilmington, Delaware, yesterday.
So we are going to be covering that.
All of that being said, let's now get into
the numbers.
And again, I am going to do a screen share
with you guys.
This seemed to work well yesterday and give
us a pretty good sense of of of what is going
on.
So let's start there.
First and foremost, what has changed since
yesterday?
Wisconsin has been called for Joe Biden with
a less than one percent margin of victory.
Donald Trump says he has filed for a recount
there and is e-mailing supporters asking for
money to fund that recount.
Michigan has also been called for Joe Biden.
And in fact, as we get slightly updated numbers,
literally as we're speaking, Michigan now,
about two and a half, two point seven points
in favor of Joe Biden, a bigger margin of
victory in both Michigan and Wisconsin.
Actually, Wisconsin is basically the same
margin of victory that Trump had over Hillary
in 2016, a larger margin of victory for Joe
Biden in Michigan this year than what Donald
Trump had over Hillary Clinton in 2016.
What is still oh, before we go any further,
Alaska has still not been called, although
we know it will go for Donald Trump, currently
leading two to one, almost with half the vote
reporting there, just slow to count.
There are a lot of rural areas, but we're
going to continue tracking and following that,
of course.
But in my count, I am already giving those
three electoral votes to Donald Trump.
In the meantime, Arizona is a source of some
controversy.
And later in today's program, I'm going to
bring you video of Trump supporters gathering
at the Capitol in Phenix, Arizona, and then
sort of moving over and joining another protest
at the Maricopa County Election Center, I
believe it's called, where they are demanding
that they count the vote and they are mad
at Fox News because not only the Associated
Press, which is what what we are using here,
but also Fox News called Arizona, although
there are people who feel it is still too
close with 88 percent reporting, Joe Biden
is up by two point four there, about sixty
eight and a half thousand votes.
So what is the race hinge on?
If we grant Joe Biden in Arizona, which most
but not all currently do, it hinges on the
states of Nevada, Pennsylvania, North Carolina
and Georgia.
And again, conceding Arizona to Joe Biden
would put him at 264 electoral votes, meaning
a win in any of these four outstanding states.
And Joe Biden would be the next president
of the United States.
The least likely for me is North Carolina,
North Carolina.
Now, the vote count has not actually moved
for a full 24 hours.
We are not exactly sure why, but North Carolina
is stuck at 94 percent.
Reporting the lead for Donald Trump right
now is about one point four percentage points,
which is equal to about 80000 votes.
I am not counting on North Carolina flipping
to Joe Biden following that, Joe Biden.
Is currently leading in Nevada now, the vote
count in Nevada yesterday stopped being updated
relatively early and it had Joe Biden up seven
tenths of a point.
That lead has now expanded as Nevada.
Again, this is as of this moment as Nevada
has gone back to counting and reporting votes.
Joe Biden's lead has gone from seven tenths
of a point.
To nine tenths of a point, the path for Biden
to win is that of majority, an important amount
of the remaining votes are from the Vegas
area, which went for Hillary Clinton in 2016,
anticipating it would go for Joe Biden.
Now, that's the argument for Nevada.
With those six electoral votes, Joe Biden
would get to 270, presuming nothing changes
in Arizona, which has been called.
We then have the very curious case of Pennsylvania
and to explain what's happening in Pennsylvania,
understand that this was the Red Mirage scenario
state.
Pennsylvania does not start counting mail
in ballots until the polls close on Election
Day, Pennsylvania expected to have favorable
numbers for Trump in in-person voting, favorable
numbers for Joe Biden in vote by mail.
And indeed, on election night, Donald Trump
had a lead of eight, even nine or 10 points.
Thinking back to different moments on election
night and overtime, that lead started to shrink
yesterday when I came to you, Joe Biden was
down about seven points in Pennsylvania.
And now as the vote has been counted, as you
can see here with this very interesting chart
from The New York Times that I'm showing people
as the vote count has gone, Trump's biggest
lead was right at about 55 percent.
As the vote count has increased, it has narrowed,
narrowed, narrowed, now considered one point
eight points by The New York Times and officially,
according to the Associated Press, also one
point eight points separating Donald Trump
and Joe Biden.
That is about one hundred and sixteen thousand
vote lead for Trump.
The path here for Biden, if you believe there
is one, is that there are a bunch of ballots
from Pittsburgh which cannot even legally
be counted until tomorrow, and that as the
Philadelphia votes continue to be counted,
the margins will continue to shrink for Donald
Trump and maybe flip to Joe Biden.
Of course, if Joe Biden wins Pennsylvania,
he wins the election.
We then have Georgia, as you can see, in Georgia.
Also, Donald Trump's biggest lead coming right
around 33 percent of the vote being counted
from that point forward.
As more and more of the vote has been counted,
Donald Trump's lead has shrunk and shrunk
and shrunk to the point that his lead is now
a mere zero point three percentage points,
or about thirteen thousand five hundred votes.
We have ninety nine percent reporting in Georgia
so that at this point, I don't even want to
go into the various models claiming to know
how likely is it that it would go one way?
How likely is it that it would go the other
way?
It's extraordinarily close.
And if indeed it is the Atlanta ballot that
remains out, it could get even closer and
maybe Joe Biden could win it or maybe not.
So it is now down to these four states.
Now, it goes without saying, as I pull up
the map, if we give Arizona to Joe Biden,
as the Associated Press has done, Ostry and
Utah, of course, is a Trump state, as I mentioned
earlier, even though officially Alaska has
not been called for Donald Trump, I am calling
it for Donald Trump because it will ultimately
go for Donald Trump.
If Joe Biden were to win Nevada, that would
put him at two hundred and seventy electoral
votes.
And this would be over barring, of course,
recounts and lawsuits, which Donald Trump
is doing.
If Joe Biden were to flip Pennsylvania, that
would put him at two hundred and eighty four
electoral votes, also 270 above 270.
And it would secure this election if Georgia
were to flip to Joe Biden, that would put
him at 280 electoral votes, again, securing
a an electoral victory.
And if North Carolina flips to Joe Biden,
that would also put him at 279, although I
believe North Carolina is the least likely
to flip.
So we the range of scenarios that are remaining
are if Trump wins all four of these states,
Trump wins reelection with 274 electoral votes.
Imagine that Arizona were wrong.
That could put Donald Trump at 285 if Arizona
stays with Biden.
The best Biden could do if he were to get
all four remaining states, Nevada, Pennsylvania,
North Carolina and Georgia, it would put Joe
Biden at three hundred and twenty one electoral
votes.
I don't think there's any way that Biden gets
in North Carolina.
So for me, the biggest real possibility for
Biden would be 306.
I don't particularly think he gets Georgia
either.
And so if Biden were to get Nevada and Pennsylvania,
Joe Biden would win with two hundred and ninety.
My prediction was to 95.
So that could be very, very close without
Nevada.
Joe Biden would have 284 with Nevada instead
of Pennsylvania.
Joe Biden would have exactly two hundred and
seventy electoral votes.
And if that is the case, the proportional
apportionment in Nebraska could be the difference
maker.
Joe Biden got one electoral vote from the
second district in Nebraska.
If indeed this comes down to Nevada and Joe
Biden doesn't get Pennsylvania, doesn't get
Georgia, doesn't get North Carolina, Biden
will have 270 thanks to that one vote from
Nebraska.
Without it, it could be the 269 to 269 tie
scenario we've been talking about with it.
And Nevada, Joe Biden would win.
270 to 268, we may know more by tonight, we
may know more by tomorrow.
Again, checking in on the latest numbers in
Pennsylvania with the latest update.
Still a one point eight percentage point lead
for Donald Trump as votes are being counted
in Georgia, a zero point three percent lead
for Donald Trump, with 99 percent reporting.
And in Nevada, with 76 percent reporting and
more vote expected there today, a lead of
zero point nine percent for Joe Biden in the
state of Nevada.
Now, I don't even want to get ahead of myself
at this point.
There are lots of people who are very confident
that Joe Biden is going to win.
There are also a lot of people, including
Trump's entire family, who claim that Trump
has won.
They believe Trump really won Nevada.
They believe Trump won Georgia.
They believe Trump won Pennsylvania.
They even believe Trump won Michigan and even
potentially Wisconsin.
Some of them are saying so.
All we can do at this point in time is wait.
In the Senate, it is increasingly looking
like Democrats are not going to take the Senate.
Now, this was my prediction until very recently,
at which point I said there is a path for
Democrats in the Senate.
But you might recall that for the last three
years I've been saying, based on what's up
in the Senate in 2020, I don't think Democrats
have a shot.
My belief was 20, 20 has to be the year of
taking the presidency and 20, 22 may be the
year of Democrats taking the Senate because
of some very favorable polling and the feeling
of momentum over the last couple of months,
there was a credible path for Democrats to
take the Senate.
It's conceivable it could happen, but it is
not looking particularly likely.
But a very interesting Senate race is in Georgia.
In Georgia, incumbent Republican David Perdue
appeared to be winning easily in a three way
race, most prominently against Democratic
challenger John OSF.
As of right now, David Perdue, the incumbent
Republican in Georgia, is hovering right at
the 50 percent mark.
In terms of the vote in Georgia.
This is relevant because given that it's a
three way race, if no candidate gets a majority
of the vote, meaning if David Perdue ends
up with forty nine point nine percent or forty
nine point eight percent of the vote, there
would be a runoff between Perdue and OSF,
the second place challenger.
And that would be a brand new Senate race
and potentially a seat that could be flipped,
could be flipped.
So we're going to be watching that.
And then, of course, we're also looking at
the numbers in the House.
I'm going to tell you right now, we don't
have to do it now.
I am not going to participate in the stuff
of now as it's looking OK for Biden and, you
know, knock on wood.
There are already leftists starting to criticize
Joe Biden.
We're going to take things a step at a time.
We'll criticize Joe Biden if he becomes president
and does things we don't like.
OK, we're not getting into that where at some
point we will have to have a real nut, not
a mayor culpa, but a real accounting for the
problems of the Democratic Party is that it
is pointed to by the House numbers is the
point that I'm making many predictions saying,
oh, Democrats are going to dramatically expand
their lead in the House of Representatives,
and it does not yet appear as though that
is happening, although in twenty eighteen
we had to wait a little while for that to
be adjudicated.
But there is no question that we have to be
able to hold two ideas in our head at the
same time.
On the one hand, yes, many Trump are ignorant.
Yes, many trumpets are uninformed.
Many are not good people.
Many see themselves as fighting a war, as
I said yesterday, where facts don't matter
and they must defend their leader no matter
what.
That is true.
And so part of why Republicans did not get
crushed the way some some predicted has to
do with trumpets.
But we have to be able to at the same time
say if the Democratic Party faced with.
Arguably, the most incompetent president in
the modern political era, arguably the worst
major country response to the pandemic in
the world, a complete mishandling of the economy
on and on and on.
If given all of that, Democrats end up losing
seats in the House.
We can't just blame Trump.
And that's exactly how Democrats will continue
to lose if they say it's just stupid Trump
because it's not it's partially stupid trumpet's.
The Democratic Party has responsibility and
we're not going to get ahead of ourselves,
but maybe it'll be tomorrow, maybe it'll be
Monday, maybe it'll be the following month.
I don't know when it's going to be, but I
am taking notes.
I have copious notes, as some like to say,
about the failings of the Democratic Party,
and there will be a time for that.
So I know people have started emailing me
saying, David, why are you talking about this?
That the other thing about the Democratic
Party, it's not time yet is we do things when
they're when it is the time to do it.
I even got emails this morning from people
saying, how do you see 20, 24?
No guys know when in 2017 people asked me
about twenty twenty.
I said, we've got a midterm.
First, we need to focus on the midterm.
We are not even done with this election yet.
So we are going to take it a step at a time,
as I always insist that we should be doing.
Glad you're with us today.
I will be live later today.
I hope you will join me on YouTube, Twitter
and Facebook with continued results.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about Trump's lawsuits.
We will talk about Rudy Giuliani and Eric
Trump's stunt in Philadelphia.
We will talk about Trump's spiritual adviser,
I guess, trying to strike out the demons that
may be preventing Donald Trump from winning.
We have all of it.
And I want to hear what is on your mind.
I am on Twitter at David Pakman.
Make sure you're following me there.